meantime a local high school student is
also calling for change after he says
he's been discriminated against the teen
tells 8 news now he's been cyber bullied
and threatened for about two years after
he started a club at school promoting
pro-life and now he's taking legal
action sasha loftus joins us tonight
with more
yes denise here's a look at the letter
attorneys sent to the clark county
school district this week the student i
spoke with tonight says he resorted to
this kind of action to help others avoid
what he told me he's gone through
it's been incredibly you know stressful
for me high school student felipe avila
describes what he calls a difficult few
years
often times you know i just couldn't
believe that this was happening avila
says since he started a students for
life club on campus here at east career
and technical academy two years ago he's
been attacked bullied and discriminated
against there have been anonymous
accounts that have issued threats that
have called for my suicide he tells 8
news now he reached out to the school's
administration for help multiple times
to no avail i tried as much as i could
to
give screen shots to give information to
hold these students accountable so he
decided to take legal action with help
from the thomas more society their
attorneys sent this letter to district
leaders wednesday claiming the academy
is discriminating against the students
for life club in violation of federal
law what i want from the school district
is to just respect the rights the
constitutional rights of students like
me felipe hopes to see change here but
he says he didn't just make this move
for himself
he hopes to help others also find their
voice i think it's so important that
students regardless of you know whether
they're left leaning right leaning
pro-choice pro-life
they have a right to speak
i reached out to the clark county school
district about this they responded over
email saying they are reviewing this
letter that was sent we do have a copy
of that on our website 8newsnow.com